foreign
foreign
medical self-help is an emergency
measure to be used only in cases of
sudden or extraordinary misfortune
if people require Medical Care in the
course of normal everyday living they
should always be treated by a doctor
however when disaster strikes you may
not be able to obtain trained Medical
Aid in time
there are many forms of disaster they
can happen to you and your family at any
moment
this film is one of a series on medical
self-help its purpose is to teach you
what to do in an emergency situation
when there is no doctor
this powerful x-ray machine a tool of
Medical Science is being used for
healing purposes
the radiant energy it emits is able to
kill all living tissue within its being
both sick and healthy cells of the human
body
it's invisible Rays so highly
penetrative that protective shielding
with lead glass windows must be used
x-rays are much like the gamma rays of
radioactive fallout
we began our picture with x-rays because
you are all to some degree familiar with
their effects
but radioactive fallout is another
matter
if you're like most people it creates
many questions in your mind and you have
doubtless read or heard some falsehoods
and misconceptions
this film will tell you what you need to
know about Fallout so that if our
country is ever subjected to a nuclear
attack
you can help yourself and your family to
survive its dangers
for Fallout is probably the most
dangerous product of nuclear disaster in
terms of the number of people who could
be affected
it is also the one from which we are
best able to protect ourselves
let's examine what happens when a
nuclear weapon is exploded near the
Earth
first there is blast or the pressure
wave created by the explosion along with
heat the most intense ever created on
Earth
both will extend great distances from
the point of the explosion from 1 to 20
or 25 miles depending on the size of the
weapon
however the further away you are from
the site of the explosion the less are
the chances you will suffer the Fatal
effects of blast and Heat
there is yet a third immediate result of
a nuclear detonation initial radiation
the final effect is residual radiation
the main concern of this film or
radiation that follows the explosion and
one that may remain at high altitude for
some time before falling back to Earth
what exactly is residual radiation
our son like other Stellar bodies of the
universe is a giant nuclear furnace
burning at temperatures of millions of
degrees
while emitting various types of
radiation
among these are gamma rays
shorter in wavelength than their closest
neighbor
x-rays
the Earth's atmosphere prevents these
radiations dangerous to the health of
man and animal from reaching our planet
however when a nuclear weapon is
exploded man is creating on Earth in the
splitting of atomic nuclei his own
nuclear furnace to produce the gamma and
beta radiations of outer space
let's see now just how this radiation is
created
at the time of the burst vast amounts of
dirt Stone and other debris vaporized by
the heat of the explosion are sucked up
into the rising cloud
as the mushroom cloud forms these
particles are made radioactive or as
they cool and condense they are
contaminated by residue from the bomb
these particles when they fall back to
Earth are what we call radioactive
fallout
can you or anyone else predict with
accuracy the pattern by which fallout
particles will return to Earth
the answer is no for Fallout will depend
on the number size and location of
nuclear weapons exploded and the
direction of upper air currents
let's for example explore the Fallout
produced by one of these nuclear weapons
it sends its column of radioactive
material up to 80 000 feet or about 16
miles or more above the Earth
here the radioactive particles beginning
to drift downward are at the mercy of
upper air currents that vary from day to
day
descending at various altitudes through
many different layers of air that may be
moving at varying speed and direction
thus winds on the surface of the Earth
give little help in determining the
direction or the occurrence of Fallout
meteorologists with their special
instruments however can appraise
altitudes as well as the total distance
Fallout will be carried
in a nuclear attack keep tuned to your
local radio station it will keep you
posted where Fallout is taking place and
it's the proximate amount
though you may be able to see this dust
once it reaches the Earth you cannot see
or detect the radiation it emits without
the aid of radiological instruments nor
can you taste smell or feel this
radiation
why is Fallout so dangerous to human and
animal life
because each particle gives off
radiation as if it were a tiny x-ray
machine
this radiation consists mainly of gamma
rays which are extremely penetrating
like x-rays
gamma rays are able to injure even
destroy the cells of our body if we are
exposed to a sufficient dosage long
enough or if we eat or drink material
contaminated by Fallout particles
exposure to gamma rays can make you sick
can even cause death
however no matter how long one may be
exposed to Fallout he does not become
radioactive nor can anyone catch
radiation sickness from him like a
contagious disease
in fact this radiation cannot make
anyone or anything Radioactive
now let us suppose that Fallout has
descended on this can we'll let salt
represent Fallout dust
the particles don't go through the tin
the radiation does but radiation is
harmless to all except living materials
it has no effect on the food inside
now if you wipe away the Fallout
particles or better still wash them away
the food inside cannot be contaminated
and is perfectly safe to eat
the same is true of all foods and
liquids that have been protected by
packagings or containers even the
thinnest layer of cellophane if you
don't swallow the Dutch there is no ill
effect
if water for washing is in short supply
canned goods that may have been exposed
to Fallout can be handled safely with a
piece of paper towel
use one sheet of paper to lift the can
and turn it upside down there is no dust
on the bottom now dispose of the paper
wipe the sides of the can with a new
piece of towel
and don't forget to put the contaminated
paper in a covered receptacle
now open the Clean top
there will be no harmful particles in
the food itself
a sealed loaf of bread that has been
exposed to fall out can be salvaged in a
similar manner
turn the loaf upside down to expose the
bottom which will be clear of dust then
dispose of the towel
now insert a sharp knife through the wax
paper at the center of the loaf and cut
upwards making a slot four or five
inches lengthwise
insert your fingers through the slot and
rip the paper slowly open
the bread can be safely removed to a
clean plate
finally dispose of the wax paper
contaminated vegetables such as potatoes
can be paired like this
use a clean piece of newspaper and
working first in one corner cut off one
end
move to a clean surface of the paper and
peel in this manner
move to another area of the paper and
remove the other end
dispose of all peelings and soiled paper
carefully
after handling any contaminated food
containers or vegetables wash your hands
Fallout dust is dangerous but it can be
dealt with by following safe procedures
there is another widespread Legend
the fear that Fallout spells death to
all life on Earth
the plain fact is that even if a great
number of nuclear weapons were exploded
the resulting Fallout would cover only a
small area of the world's total land
mass
the real concern then is this if we are
in that area
how do we protect ourselves
like x-rays radiation from Fallout can
go through almost every kind of building
material
over 99 percent would pass through glass
66 through wood sheathing
50 through a brick veneer wall
but only one percent of gamma radiation
would penetrate 18 inches of concrete
and though it's not a building material
it's important to know that only one
percent would pass through 25 inches of
Earth
quite aside from the shielding effect of
building materials the intensity of
radiation decreases with the square of
the distance from the source
thus
10 feet away from a particle of Fallout
the radiation rate is only one percent
of that encountered at a distance of one
foot
other things being equal the central
parts of a building are safer
the radiation rate or the intensity from
Fallout decreases with the passage of
time in fact for every seven-fold
increase in time the radiation will be
reduced by a factor of 10.
that means that at seven hours after the
explosion the radiation level will be
about 10 percent of its intensity at one
hour
at 49 hours it will be about one percent
within two weeks the radiation rate can
be expected to Decay to about one tenth
of one percent
therefore the most vital period to seek
protection from Fallout is the first few
days after nuclear attacks even more so
the first few hours
but remember
even with the passage of time a low
level of radiation can be dangerous that
is why you may need to remain within a
sheltered area for as long as two weeks
these then are the three basic factors
in protection against Fallout
time distance and shielding
time meaning the longer you stay
protected from Fallout the safer you
will be
distance or the further away you get
from Fallout the safer you will be
shielding meaning The more mass or
weight you put between yourself and
Fallout the safer you will be
you have often seen this sign on
buildings it means that indoors is a
public fallout shelter one of many and
various kinds of buildings in your
community that are similarly identified
Architects and Engineers have carefully
surveyed the shielding qualities of
these areas to ensure they offer a
minimum protection factor of 40 or more
meaning that in the event of Fallout
from a nuclear explosion the mass and
weight this shelter will place between
you and the source of radiation will
make you at least 40 times safer than if
you were Outdoors
each of these shelters will hold at
least 50 people
and has been stocked by the government
with austere supplies
food
water
sanitation equipment
medical kit and radiological instruments
but what about Millions who live in
suburbs or rural areas often far beyond
quick walking distance of the nearest
public shelters
with foresight you can have a home
shelter for the protection of your
family built from specifications and
cost estimates for various types of
shelters provided by your local civil
defense office
the home shelter should be stocked with
supplies of food and water sufficient
for two weeks
here you are afforded time distance and
shielding if and when Fallout so
dangerous to human health should ever
occur in your community
just how much radiation can you receive
without becoming sick
we measure exposure to gamma radiation
from Fallout in units called Renton
they're the same units used to measure
x-rays named for wilheim Conrad Renkin
the discoverer of x-rays
people and animals May develop radiation
sickness if they have been exposed to
large amounts of radiation over a short
period of time
few people become sick who have been
exposed to a total radiation dose of 100
rankins or less
however exposure to more than 300
rankins over a period of a few days will
cause sickness may cause death
and if you receive an exposure of 600
rankins in that same period of time
death is almost certain
how can you tell just how much radiation
you've been exposed to
these are the instruments commonly used
to detect and measure radiation
they are part of the equipment supplied
to the radiological monitoring team of
every public shelter
with them you can determine not only the
total amounts of radiation received but
also the dose rate per unit of time or
the dose rate in renkins per hour
this is the dosimeter conveniently
shaped to be worn on one person at all
times
it is able to measure the total
accumulated radiation exposure in Renton
the charger adjusts the dosimeter to a
zero reading prior to its use with each
separate exposure to radiation building
cumulatively on the dosimeter gauge so
that a reading of the total dose is
available at any given time
next the geiger counter this instrument
measures radiation in fractions of
renkins per hour within or outside the
shelter
finally the survey meter able to measure
higher intensities of radiation that may
exist outside the shelter
foreign
for home shelters detection and
measuring instruments are available from
commercial sources
however most householders will rely
cheaply on their portable radios to
receive readings as they are taken by
civil defense monitoring teams
if there is a nuclear attack and you
survive the initial effects of an
explosion you will have at least a half
hour to get to a public or home fallout
shelter
therefore to be safe from radiation
sickness get into the best available
shelter as soon as possible
once there stay put because each time
you're exposed to Fallout radiation over
a period of a few days
the dosage continues to build until it
reaches dangerous quantity
if you're among those compelled to
travel through a fallout area on
essential errands there are certain
rules to follow
protect your body with boots or rubbers
gloves headgear and outer clothing that
can be removed before you re-enter the
shelter
on returning brush off the rest of your
clothing thoroughly as well as any parts
of your body that may have been exposed
to Fallout
if sufficient water is available wash
your face and hands carefully
remember these are the dosages of
radiation as they affect human health
100 renkins little or no effects
300 renkins sickness or death
600 renkins death
recovery from radiation sickness is
nothing new patients who are treated by
x-rays routinely experiences sickness
and get over it of course the dosages
they receive are carefully measured
just as in combating the virus of the
common cold your general state of health
will often govern how quickly you can
throw off the effects of mild or
moderate radiation sickness
in an emergency situation where there is
no doctor always treat radiation
Sickness by treating its symptoms
in fact these symptoms are often similar
to those produced by extreme anxiety or
emotional stress
so it's best not to try to determine
their cause
I repeat do not try to diagnose merely
treat the symptoms just as you would if
they were the result of any other type
of illness
these are the symptoms of mild as well
as moderate radiation sickness one or
more of which may appear shortly after
exposure to Fallout
fatigue
loss of appetite
nausea
vomiting
prostration
the treatment
is red
or nausea you may give the patient any
of the commercial preparations that
settle an upset stomach
or one half teaspoon of baking soda in a
cup of water
tea and other hot liquids may be helpful
when a high fever is present apply cold
wet packs aspirin also tends to reduce a
fever
in severe radiation sickness along with
the early symptoms other symptoms may
appear a week or more after exposure
recovery is possible but it'll take
longer
the symptoms
are diarrhea
inflammation of mouth and throats
loss of hair
for treatment
control the diarrhea
and give aspirin and warm water gargles
people are naturally alarmed at the
thought of bodily changes that may
follow severe radiation sickness such as
loss of hair or sterility
these conditions are usually temporary
and will disappear with recovery
so I hope we've dispelled another
commonly held myth
you can get over radiation sickness just
as you get over many others nevertheless
don't minimize the danger of Fallout
remember its effects are cumulus is
the only real protection against it is
to take shelter
now let's review some of the outstanding
facts we have learned in this brief
exploration of a vitally important
subject
Fallout is composed of trillions of
particles of dust that are made
Radioactive by residue from the nuclear
weapon during the aftermath of the
explosion
in a nuclear attack depend on your local
radio station to tell you where Fallout
is taking place
you may be able to see some of the
Fallout dust when it reaches the Earth
but you cannot taste smell or feel the
radiation itself
the gamma rays given off by Fallout are
able to injure or destroy the living
cells of our body if we are exposed long
enough
food or water in containers that prevent
contamination by Fallout dust is
perfectly safe
radiation is harmful only to living
tissues
packaged foods that have been exposed to
Fallout should be opened carefully
by following proper procedures you can
eat such foods without danger to health
radiation can pass through most building
materials but its intensity is
diminished in proportion to the weight
and mass of the material or the
shielding the intensity also decreases
with distance from The Fallout
the radiation rate will decrease or
Decay rapidly with time
it is most dangerous in the first few
days after explosion thus the three
basic factors that protect you from
Fallout radiation are time distance and
shielding
you should know the location of the
nearest public shelter in your community
inside it you will be at least 40 times
safer from Fallout than you would be
outdoors
and it has been stocked with supplies to
sustain its occupants for up to two
weeks
if you're not within walking distance of
a public shelter you can provide a
satisfactory home shelter for your
family
radiation is invisible but we have
accurate instruments with which to
measure it in Renkin units
the dosimeter can be worn on the person
and measures the accumulated radiation
exposure the total dose at any given
time
the geiger counter measures radiation in
fractions of renkins per hour inside or
outside the shelter
the survey meter is used to measure the
higher intensities of radiation that may
be present outside the shelter
assuming that you have the protection of
a good shelter within a half hour after
nuclear attacks you will probably have
little or no radiation sickness
if there are victims who appear to have
radiation sickness do not diagnose
treat the symptoms
perhaps the most important thing you
have learned is to see the danger in its
true perspective
make no mistake nuclear attacks would be
a terrible catastrophe
millions of our people would be killed
by the initial blast and Heat
Millions more would be threatened by
Death from radioactive fallout
but that is a threat that can be
combated
can with knowledge
preparation and courage
the faith and conquer
[Music]